thank you
foreign
I push that
I love you and then that when it comes
on yeah
[Music]
wrong
we go I'm getting my training good
morning everybody I'm not sure if that's
going to stay on and hopefully you can
hear me clearly morning and welcome to
the planning meeting
um today's date is the
27th of September
um this meeting is being live streamed
we are using microphones for members to
be able to speak and members of the
public to be able to speak to the items
so please if you are a member wanting to
speak if you can indicate clearly by
raising your hand so that the Gentlemans
with the microphones can come along to
you give them time to get to you so you
can speak fully into the microphone and
can be heard
on the webcasting and otherwise
so obviously we're here at the
Buckland athletic center
we're not expecting any fire alarms if
we do have a fire alarm please do leave
the building by the nearest door and
assembling the car park if you've got
any mobile phones with you can I ask
everybody to put them onto silence so
the meeting isn't Disturbed
um members of the public when it is your
turn to speak I will call you to the
front there's a table at the side there
with a microphone for you to to use and
you'll be shown how to use that and just
speak into the microphone clearly
hopefully I've learned my training
enough so you can hear me clearly at the
moment
um just as a matter of interest you
would have three minutes to address the
committee for the minor applications and
five minutes as major
could I just mention to members as well
please note that if you're not in the
meeting for the entire item you cannot
vote on the application
um can I also ask you
um
to keep your points short and do not
interrupt when someone is speaking
um okay
I think that's everything so we will
then go on to the agenda per se please
um and the minutes of the last meeting
held on the 16th of August
our members are happy for me to sign
that hopefully you've had a chance to
consider the minutes are you happy for
me to can I have a proposer please to
thank you councilor Haynes and second by
councilor Parker
thank you can we take a vote to accept
those as read can I also mention Rob
Hayes wasn't trained but he wanted to be
mentioned that he was there thank you
so we've accepted those as right
um can I ask for apologies for absence
please
thank you chair apologies received from
councilors Cole Clough Jackie hook
Jeffrey and pit
councilor Jackie hook has a substitute
that would that is councilor Alan
connett
that's right thank you
um can I ask for any Declarations of
interest from members
councilor Dewhurst please start name
okay
thank you very much yes good morning
um thank you chair I would like to
declare an interest in item 6B which is
the field dawlish worm it's for a
holiday park and I'm the owner of a
holiday park on the other side of
teambridge
um so I don't have any kind of pecuniary
Interest or anything like that it is
completely on the other side of the of
the district so I'm I'm not going to
leave the room but I shouldn't say
anything or speak or vote on that okay
thank you thank you for that did
counselor Nutley think you were next and
then councilor Clarence
yeah thank you chair I'm not sure
whether we need to but on the Dartmouth
National Park we tend to declare
interest should we receive emails and
letters which I think probably most of
us have done with regards the Riverside
boat club but whether we need to declare
interest here I don't know thank you for
that Council counseling I'm going to
talk about that shortly thank you
councilor Clarence
uh thank you chairman yes I am 20
00961 major Riverside boat yard uh as a
boat owner who's who in the past has
laid up boats at various times in this
yard for the winters I'm declaring an
interest in this application and we're
drawing from taking part in the
determination of this application
coupled with the fact that I know the
applicant quite well and are fairly only
right and proper that others should
determine this application thank you
thank you Julie noted I have seemed to
have skipped
I do seem to have skipped over an
announcement that I need to make at the
start of the the meeting
um
I would like to say that
um
I would like to propose
um a deferral for item 6C the Riverside
Boatyard in timmouth
this is because there's been a lot of
late information in circulation from the
applicant to all members
um officers and
um us as members need to be concerned
that all parties have not had a chance
to consider all of the the information
that seems to have come in
um so we need to be able to review and
to be able to comment on this and to be
able to make a firm decision as a
council
so I would like to propose that this is
deferred allowing us all parties
to look at these late representations so
we can at the next meeting be able to
consider and make a judgment on this
so I've asked I'm proposing it can I ask
if anyone would second me at that please
councilor Nutley thank you
can I ask all members of the committee
to to vote on that please whether you're
happy to do so thank you
so there's the fours
okay
any against
any abstentions
thank you
and I appreciate to um
I should have said that before we had
the uh Declarations of Interest I
apologies
um so from the point of view of planning
applications to consider
so let's move on to the first item
please
one Higher Holcomb Drive tinmouth
can I pass to officers to take me
through that please
thank you chair there's no updates for
this application
this application seeks permission for a
first floor extension extensions to the
garage a single story lean-to and works
to the front of the property
is a detached Bungalow it's
it's number one Higher Holcomb drive but
it faces onto higher Holcomb road you
can see on the site location plan here
and it's currently got a attached garage
as you can see it's a fairly shallow
pitched single story bungalow
so the proposal is to
um
have reverse level accommodations so the
bedroom is provided on the ground floor
and then the living areas will be on the
first floor
um so part the Riff extension is to
erect uh Dormers to both the front and
rear of the property there's a Juliet
Balcony on the west elevation and then a
Terrace area to the front
so this is the property as existing
so number 18 High Holcomb road is
located to the rear of the property so
this is the rendered property on the
left hand side here
numbers 13 and 15 High Hopkins Road
located opposite as you can see they
currently have a uh the same roof form
as proposed for the current application
this is numbers 3 to 15 higher Holcomb
drive again you can see they've got uh
sticky pictures with first of all
accommodation
um
so just to confirm the windows in the
rear elevation are proposed to be
obscurely glazed and also the when
they're in the first window in the East
Elevation to prevent any
I'm overlooking or lots of privacy
impacts upon even number 18 High Holcomb
Road or number three higher Holcomb
Drive
the reputation is for approval subjects
and conditions are set out a report
thank you very much we do have a speaker
supporter who wanted to to speak on this
um
Gary Brown
if you'd like to come forward please
it should be counselor sorry it should
be Graham Turner first I believe got
that here sorry
I beg your pardon I'm looking at the
wrong list
it's okay apologies
thank you I've got it here
to refer to during our objection
S no I'm sorry if you want to leave it
if you want to leave it up the front
here
so I just dropped my documents on the
way and before we start the objection
sorry could you set a set on I'm sorry
[Music]
yeah he needs to sit by the microphone
so I didn't I didn't realize that I do
apologize and before we start the
objection can I just confirm that the
migration of the portal the planning
portal at teambridge
um has captured the consistent 30 well
for this application sorry 30 almost 30
objections because when I looked on the
portal on the front page it shows five
plus the town council's objection but
there are actually 30 and they've
consistently been that to this proposal
so we confirm that the councils have
seen all those objections
oh sorry thank you chair and the
officers report
um note 17 objections have been received
and there has been no identified
incidents in the migration between our
two back office systems of objections
not being properly transferred between
the two
um so it would be incredibly unlucky if
this that had happened in this case
obviously members have full access to
the to the files and the representations
that we have received are summarized in
the report and we're just double
checking in the back office system the
number of contributors that we perceived
um and we uh consulted I was 44 and
we've received 17 objections to the 17
uh individual
parties who have submitted responses
they may in some instance have submitted
duplicate responses which may account
for the the 30 figure
well thank you very much for your
clarification chair thank you
uh we object on the following grounds
the first is over development visual
impact not in keeping and loss of
privacy the this is the third
application uh it's increased the height
of the building by 1.4 meters from the
2020 application making it four meters
higher than the current building that's
equivalent to putting it on top of
itself including the rich the living
areas on the first floor will look out
across and down into neighbor's houses
affecting immunity and privacy it will
massively impact the street scene
currently buildings complement each
other are considerate in height and
positioning and we think this is
overbearing top heavy and unsuitable
being shoehorned onto a small site
the properties to the side number three
and behind number 18 and number 20 will
be greatly affected the owners of number
three have established it will affect
sunlight reaching their 20 year old
Greenhouse vegetable patch and small
garden
a window on the west elevation provides
light and Immunity into number three the
height and proximity of the new roofs
Gable wall and the living area will
reduce this greatly
we strongly disagree with the officer's
assessment of the impact of the height
and proximity The Proposal will have on
number 18. it's always benefited from
sunshine on the Southwest elevation
heating the house during the winter
months item 3.19 carbon and climate
impact the officer explains the benefits
of the south facing windows and solar
gain in the winter months the new build
will be enjoying however this is to the
detriment of number 18 who will now lose
their established solar gain due to the
height and proximity of the proposed
roof structure
our second objection is parking and road
safety the design statement asserts all
vehicles owned by the applicant will be
accommodated off the highway we strongly
disagree the garage can barely
accommodate a small car at an angle we
doubt the hard standing would
accommodate the owner's yellow van on
its large yellow van which is kept on
the road outside with an additional car
the van is limited the view of traffic
to navigating in both directions and
some objectives were mentioned
witnessing utility vehicles mounting the
road to get through finally precedent
higher Holcomb Road Drive and close make
up the neighborhood the applicant's
property is prominently and centrally
located in its neighborhood there are 33
single-story Bungalows located in these
three roads not one has undergone the
removal of its roof and the addition of
living space the applicant seeks to
carry out allowing this application was
set a precedent and could fundamentally
and detrimentally imp attack the
pleasant and considered design of this
neighborhood in conclusion we ask the
committee to carefully consider 3.11 of
the case officers report there is a
policy reference to wae 8 item C and the
committee should carefully consider the
30 the objections that we have said we
do not believe that this does meet
that criteria
Turner
could I call the supporter please
Mrs Brown or if you'd like to take the
seat at the table there thank you
could you say your name please yes
hello everybody I'm Angelica scenes and
I'm here today with my partner Gary
bound
thank you when you start speaking you
have three three minutes thank you okay
um we bought this property as our
long-term home hopefully our forever
home
we're looking for some additional
accommodation accessible accommodation
not only for our future needs but to
accommodate our current and increasing
caring responsibilities with the sole
carer of for Paddy who's a 67 year old
relative who's recently had a major
stroke and has a chronic condition that
will require major surgery in the next
few years and we're primary carers for
my Father John 83 years old who's
widowed and for Gary's widowed 79 year
old mother
the addition of dedicated office space
will allow me to increase my working
from home arrangements as these caring
responsibilities increase and the
redesign to make the ground floor
accessible will provide for respite care
now longer term options should any of
them need it and for our future
we also be able to accommodate more
easily visits from family who live
elsewhere in the country as they all are
increasingly finding traveling difficult
the garage and the Improvement to the
hard Landscaping will improve off street
parking the mention of the van and the
small car we have I hope would be
accommodated there but I can certainly
assure the committee that knowing issues
have been raised with us by any of our
neighbors about the parking of the van
we have however read in detail all of
the 17 objections and are committed to
working collaboratively with our
neighbors should the committee be minded
to approve on any of those incidental
issues
um we also plan to landscape the garden
you'll have seen it's in a bit of a
scruffy State
um we are absolutely committed to doing
that in line with biodiversity and Eco
rules and regulations but more than that
we really do want to enhance the look of
the property it does need improving
in relation to those specific objectives
that um Graeme from has mentioned as I
say we've read all 17 and we are
committed to trying to work with our
neighbors collaboratively in relation to
number three I would refer the committee
to the officers report paragraph 3.13 to
objections from number 18 specifically
referenced the committee would be
looking at paragraph 3.12 number 20
there's no specific reference in the
officers report but the issues that were
raised today have been addressed
we've worked consistently with team
bridge planning department during
previous applications and significant
pre-planning advice to develop a design
that finds favor with the officer the
design is significantly different to
earlier iterations we have listened to
our neighbors which is why this is the
third application and made adjustments
we've worked proactively with the
planning department to ensure that the
proposals fit comfortably within the
requirements of local and National
planning policy the design is developed
to sit comfortably in the seats in the
street scheme and will be much more in
line with the line of the roost that you
saw earlier from our neighbors thank you
very much for your time well thank you
very much
foreign
we've now heard from the objector and
supporter do we have Ward members
president who would like to speak please
I noticed Council
okay
no I'm just no
okay we will then move on and
um
open up for debate
thank you very much Council McGregor
please
thank you chair
um in in terms of the report uh
conclusion 3.2
um having considered what may be
permissible through permitted
development rights it can you can the
officer expand a little on that so that
everybody understands what that actually
means
um I'm aware obviously that the the
government introduced in 2020 uh changes
that allowed people to insert whole
stories into their properties if
necessary and if it would be helpful I
think for the
um for the committee to have that
explained in a little bit more detail so
that they can understand
um the process thank you
ask if you can roll the elevations of
things again
will do yes so Gary can can do that
while I um I've just pulled up the
permitted development rights um I was
running through my head while while um
uh the the speakers were talking and so
there is a new permitted development
right you have to submit a prior
approval application we've had a few of
these
um actually a number in Timber
um uh and a couple in in Kenton so
um in a in a this Bungalow we don't
think would be able to accommodate an
ordinary Loft conversion because the
roof pitch is so low so you wouldn't be
able to get Dormers or or vlux or
whatever into
facilitate any well you can see on on
that
um that image there the the pitch of the
Gable there is very modest the roof
height so you'd struggle to get any
additional accommodation that way
um but councilman McGregor
um referred to the new permitted
development right for Upward extensions
that has been introduced where there is
a possibility
of applying for a class A A additional
story on a property that does come with
caveats and we are we have had uh appeal
success and we've also lost appeals when
it comes to consideration of design
matters and we both in timmouth we won
one appeal and we lost another where we
said the properties would end up being
out of keeping with the street scene and
so there is relatively early legislation
in terms of the way that it's applied at
the moment and the consistency of
decision making that we're getting from
from pins on behalf of central
government and however importantly
um you can do a at least a single story
extension I think a single story
property can go up by one story and you
should not exceed the height of your
property by three and a half meters so
essentially it's a full additional story
on top and three and a half meters so
this one there the proposal is to go for
um a relatively steeply pitched Chalet
Bungalow so with the dormas in the sides
which
um complements the accommodation in the
name neighboring properties when you
look along higher Holcomb close or drive
I'm sorry drive along the top you've got
those relatively steeply
um pointed Gables with the Dormer
windows along the sides and that's
that's where they've taken their
um uh their cues from in this proposal
and it may be slightly above the three
and a half meters but given that they
could do the three and a half
subject to complying with the other
restrictions of permitted development
and given that we think that this is a
well-designed scheme that
um
respects the design of the existing
properties in in the um local area on
balance we think this one's okay
okay thank you for that
counselor Dewhurst he wanted to come in
on this please
that thank you chair yes having having
looked at it and seen the pictures
um I'd like to propose as set out but
with one Amendment
um because I noticed
on Google Earth that it is in fact quite
close to a field and a rural area lots
of gardens in the area
and yep there
um and so I'd like to propose an
amendment whereby there is uh provision
for Hedgehog highways made in the
boundary I don't know if this is
possible because of course it's not the
boundary is not part of the application
here but I'm sure as we've got uh burden
bat boxes and things that that would be
possible
um because we we do know that hedgehogs
uh travel at least two kilometers in an
evening
thanks okay thank you
thank you very much and that's been
seconded by councilor pedrick
um any other any other speakers or any
comments from offices on the
um
that potential
Edition
um I I'm not sure when it whether any
proposed changes are are included to the
to the boundary treatments here but we
can certainly update condition four to
say that if the boundary achievements
are being amended then they should
include Hedgehog holes that's I don't
see that that's unreasonable
um and I suspect that having heard this
conversation the applicant should
probably do it anyway
um but we can you know we can certainly
include it as a compliance condition
that if the boundaries are being amended
then provision for hedgehogs be made
okay thank you any of those speakers on
this item please
no
so we have a proposal
um by cancer Dewhurst we have a
we have a second we can move that a
little bit away from me asking to be
interfering with the electronics here we
have a sector from Council petric so can
I ask members to go to the vote on this
as set out
so keep your hands up while we're
Counting
and against
any abstentions
so with line four that is carried thank
you very much
I realized that I haven't actually
clarified a point on the third item we
were going to look at today which is the
Riverside Boatyard and I didn't formally
announce the actual voting for that one
so I'm just going to quickly do that
before we move on to the next item
apologies to members present so the
result of a vote
to
defer the third item for The Boathouse
um was 10-4 none against and three
abstention so it is carried that we'll
be deferring that I just wanted to
clarify that sorry
I'll move on to the second item
which is the field dawlish Warren
I know we do have
um
speakers for that as well but we'll if I
could ask is it Gary again to take us
through this one thank you
cool
thank you
thank you chair um there's two updates
on this application
um firstly with regards to the
unilateral undertaking for the habitat
mitigation contribution as per the
update sheet
the contribution map has been confirmed
by the council's biodiversity officer to
be eight thousand and ninety five pounds
and 36 Pence the applicant has been
informed of this and they amended
unilateral and taking was received last
night
um
so the application is recommended for
approvals subject to the sign in and
clarification from our legal department
at the unilateral and taking agreement
is acceptable
and the second update again just to
clarify from the committee report the
applicants confirmed that a new hedge
has been planted along the eastern
boundary to the site and approximately
450 plants have been planted
so moving on to the presentation this
application seeks permission for a
change of use of the site known as the
fields in Warren Road Dallas Warren to
be used as a campsite the processed for
26 Bell tents to be erected in addition
proposal comprise of free buildings so
be a toilet and shower block a reception
block and a communal Barn picnic area
The Proposal also includes the provision
of car parking within the site
so as you can see the site is located on
the corner of Warren Road and Mount
Pleasant Road
it does it previously formed one large
field it's since been divided up into
two separate fields and the applicant
owns the section on the west hand side
so the site plan in front of you shows
the layout of the site so the access
from Warren roads was approved
previously and that's now been
implemented so the car parking air will
be as you drive in and then the Bell
tends to be positioned across the site
with the immediate blocks immediately on
your left hand side as you drive in
so this is the toilet and shower block
um so the elevations
see the reception block and communal
Barn will be sighted next to each other
so just to confirm the site is located
outside the
um undeveloped Coast so the principle of
the proposal to be for camping site is
considered to be acceptable
so this is the
um site access as I say it's approved
previously under uh 2019 application
it's since been implemented
this will be where the car parking area
will be located
this is looking across the site these
photos were taken from beginning last
summer I understand the applicant has
used the site for a temporary pop-up
campsite using this permits development
rights for both last summer and for this
summer so the site has now changed at
this poster mail fencing with electric
hookups currently there
so this is looking towards Mount
Pleasant Road boundary
uh this is looking back across to the
site access
so this is the existing hedge along the
boundary of Mount Pleasant Road and
you've got the Residential Properties on
the other side of the road
and this is looking to towards the seven
boundary of the site where the car
parking area is located
thank you
thank you
thank you
um so we do have um speaker public
speakers for this item can I call for
the objector Please Mr Anthony James if
you'd like to come to the front please
you have three minutes from the time you
start speaking thank you
thank you
um chair committee members good morning
and thank you for allowing me to
talk to you today on behalf of the
residents of Mount Pleasant Road who
have been who have elected me to deliver
our objections on this controversial
application
we feel that it's an overdevelopment of
campsites within the Warren area
which is evidenced by the Secretary of
State regards the outcomes Golden Sands
and ladies mile
destruction to Wildlife has occurred on
the site
it's also classed into a high risk flood
area
no Works have been undertaken with
Southwest water to prevent any flooding
from the fear from
within the land or from any units placed
upon it
we've encountered noise smell from
barbecues
um
and also there is fear that in future
wood-burning stoves will be used as a
source of heating Within These Bell
tents
we also question the management style
of the applicant
we have as neighbors endured periods of
harassment threats of violence
intimidation and menacing letters
also we also question the policy that
the site has been allowed to open upon
the government stated that a site could
open on a bare grain gray Greenfield
sorry
however this site is already developed
and has been allowed to open
for two seasons they've been open it has
been open for over those time periods
we have sent our objections to the
council to the planning department who
have failed to respond accordingly and
have failed to take on our anxieties or
our concerns in relation to
um the violence we've encountered from
the owner therefore we have made a
complaint that our complaint has been
upheld at section at level two of the
complaints process and we have now
forwarded our concerns onto the
ombudsman
we as the residents hope today that the
committee
listen to our fears and our concerns of
the opening of this site
and do not allow it to happen
that's me thank you
thank you very much
we now have a
a porter and Mr Barnaby moson
good morning if you'd like to take a
seat make sure the microphone's on
and once you start speaking again you
will have three minutes
okay good morning everyone
the applicant Matthew Lane and I are
here today to provide supporting
information to this planning application
the planning application details design
and layout of the proposed campsite has
been thought out in depth with high
consideration to the surrounding area
we are a startup business and are trying
to diversify in order to provide
something different within the local
community and add a much needed economic
boost whilst also incorporating the
growing need to use green energy and
reducing carbon footprints
Matthew and I were both born and raised
and dawlish and this particular piece of
land was passed on to Matthew by his
father
the land was purchased by Matthew's
grandfather in 1957 following a long
family history and Deep Roots within
dawlish Warren
the family tradition was to give the
land to the children and this family
tradition has occurred within dawlish
Warren since the 1920s and will continue
with Matthew when the land will
eventually be passed onto his children
the land means a lot to Matthew and his
family which is why it is extremely
important to do something to be proud of
whilst contributing to the local
community that we love so much
the land is hosted temporary markets
since 1983 approved by teambridge
District Council and therefore
demonstrates the history of commercial
use unfortunately markets on this land
are not a viable option anymore due to
the decline in participation and demand
and we feel it is important for us to
diversify to continue using the land
statistics from a leading UK campsite
and outdoor accommodation booking
platform revealed at Short stays and
staycations within the UK are in high
demand and clearly trending upwards we
have been operating as a pop-up campsite
for the last two summer seasons which
has no doubt provided many benefits to
the local community and economy
we support and will continue to support
the local community and have also
received a lot of positive encouragement
from surrounding businesses
the demand for camping has been so much
that we have been fully booked on
multiple occasions which can be
demonstrated
our customer feedback tells us that many
of swapped holidays abroad for stays
closer to home and have enjoyed it so
much that they plan to continue to do so
thank you for listening
thank you very much
we've heard the public speakers are
there any Ward members who would like to
speak on this one item
absolutely I'm just asking for others
I'm in politeness thank you
um councilor Wrigley did you did you
want to speak
thank you chair
um this is an interesting site and I can
understand why the applicants want to do
something with it
I would like to draw a few things to
your attention before you go into
deliberations
firstly what the pictures don't show
that we saw on the presentation is how
much higher this field is than the road
beside it it's considerably up so it's
right
right above the houses the Bungalows
opposite
the pictures that you're seeing there
are actually from about two years ago
since then the applicant has built all
the things he's now asking planning
permission for other than the tenths the
shower blocks are there the parking is
there the road is there it's already
been done
they do say that they've operated under
a pop-up campsite regulation now that is
strictly controlled and is supposed to
be on a Greenfield site put up for a few
weeks and then cleared down and the site
returned to Greenfield
that is not how it has been operated
it hasn't been for camping which I would
take as canvas tents it has been full of
motorhomes and other vehicles it's been
a very busy site
my big concern in that is that it shows
a
disregard for the regulations under
which they were working and a disregard
for the planning given that they have
gone ahead and built all of the items
that they are requesting
but my biggest worry which is always the
worry of any development in this area is
that of drainage remember this is a
critical drainage area this is
absolutely crucial to the safety of the
residents who live in the valley below
I'll draw your attention back to the
floods of 2000 when the camp the
residential home site at the bottom of
dawlish Warren was flooded
due to drainage going into that place
it's below sea level down there
the initial objection from Southwest
water is valid in that there has been no
plan for separating runoff and sewage
water
there is still no plan
the second communication that purports
to be from Southwest water on June the
24th is in fact from the applicant
there is a statement in there that is
unverified from Southwest water and it
does not apply does not even refer to
the planning application number
without what our drainage officer asked
for right at the very beginning which is
detailed plans for how they will handle
the runoff water how they will prevent
this from being a flooding risk for
those other residents around them
I would find it if I were on the
committee very difficult to support this
no such obligation no such drainage work
has been done or certainly not evidenced
here that we have seen
I would ask this committee to do two
things to first of all investigate what
they have already done without
permission and show a valid position
rather than the two year ago photos
to defer this decision until drainage
work has been looked into and actually
delivered in terms of plans so we know
what they will do with drainage and
runoff from the site
and to investigate the veracity of the
response that's been included on the
June the 24th item purportedly from
Southwest water
so I would ask you to defer this for
further investigation albeit that this
has been under has been waiting for two
years if you don't refuse it outright
thank you very much
thank you councilor Wrigley I also have
a a message received from councilor
pedrick another Linda pedrick another of
the Northeast dawlish Ward members so
she's asked me to read this out so I'll
do that now if that's okay
um
I've thoroughly considered the
application and have a number of
concerns about the proposed development
I believe the development will impact on
reasonably on the privacy and amenity
value of the nearby residents presumably
the site when running a full capacity
would accommodate approximately a
hundred campers in Bell tents this could
lead to unacceptable noise level for the
local residents Additionally the vehicle
and pedestrian entrance to the site
doesn't benefit from adequate Street
lighting to provide a sufficient level
of lighting for pedestrians returning to
the site during the hours of Darkness
thank you
can I at this point there were some
points raised by the public speakers can
I ask and from the Ward member
councilor Wrigley can I ask for any
comments on from offices on on that
please
yes I just got back on the point around
the critical range area so I've got the
map of the critical drain chair in front
of me and the site is located outside of
it so the properties on the opposite
right side of Mount Pleasant Road are
within the critical drainage area but
the site itself is located outside of
the critical change area
thank you thank you for that Clarity
okay
um so just to build on that
um uh we have been in discussion with
um internally about Jane is because this
has been the key issue the reason why
this application has been delayed is
substantially so that we could sort out
the the site drainage issues you know
acknowledging the the con the concerns
of the local residents and and that
whilst it's not in the critical drainage
area it is obviously next to the
critical drainage area so we've been
trying to get additional information out
from the applicant um to address this
point so we are content and our
professional drainage advisor is consent
content that if the surface water runoff
which essentially is going to be that
which comes from the the buildings the
roofs of the buildings is discharged a
rate of an attenuated rate of one liter
per second into the um combined sewer
outfall pipes and Southwest water are
content so on that basis there is no
objection from our drainage colleagues
so that would be the basis on which we
were looking to take this proposal
forward
um
that can be built into the permission
whether or not that you know that that
is that Richard is content that that is
a an uh an acceptable and a suitable way
for the drainage to be mitigated and and
addressed on the site
um
uh in relation to uh other points that
were picked up you know we we are aware
that the site has been in use as a um a
temporary campsite the decision was made
that it wasn't expedient to take any
enforcement action if there were
breaches of the the permitted
development rules around the length of
time the whether it's 28 56 days if they
were open for 60 days or 65 actually by
the time you've served and notice the
chances are the summer season would be
over so in these instances given that we
had this application in with us we
didn't feel it was expedient to take any
action
um uh therefore what we think that we've
got now is an opportunity to better
regulate the way the site is used to do
the application of conditions through
um the the granting of a permission for
the site rather than it being run on the
more informal basis as a site under
permitted development rules
thank you
thank you for that
um can I ask members of the committee
and I know well to open up the debate
really are there any questions or
comments counselor con it and then
councilor Haynes thank you chairman so I
think um we're being asked whether we
want to allow an unregulated use for two
months of the year or a regulated use
for five months of the year but in
particular some questions about the
report
I noted that Southwest water appeared to
indicate they were content with an
attenuated runoff rate at one liter per
second
um no I don't understand flow rates but
help me here what happens if we have a
particularly heavy downpour and the rate
is more than one liter per second what
how does that get managed if it's a
particularly heavy downpour secondly I
noted in the southwest water comments
that they encouraged the use of water
butts that there's nothing in the
conditions that require the use of water
bats to actually further collect rain
water for example
and it struck me that perhaps we ought
to be conditioning that secondly I noted
that the
um
our officer in terms of noise nuisance
appeared in his Commodore in their
commentary to talk about quiet times and
seem to indicate that we should have a
condition that no vehicle no vehicular
movements between 11 pm and 5 AM
although indicating the quiet time could
actually be until 7 A.M and again why is
that not conditioned because given with
all we've heard about the proximity of
this site to neighboring houses on
Warren Road it just struck me that
actually we should do more to try and
absolutely nail down and minimize any
potential impact to Residents where we
minded the grant consent and thank you
chairman
um can I leave officers to come back to
us shortly I'm going to go to another
member give you some time to actually
look at those questions if that's okay
um so councilor Haynes
thank you chairman I'm picking up one of
the points that councilman college has
made about the flow rate
um can I just ask the officer while
they're looking at the details what the
actual size of the block is in terms of
you know sort of how many square meters
because that will give an indication of
um what sort of Maximum flows you might
get
um and it is only the the roof of the
toilet shower block that would actually
have these flows so that's relatively
small
on the issue of um control of the
nuisance from the site
in my experience with a site in my ward
the presence of somebody on site
I.E a warden or someone like that is an
important aspect of making sure that
these things are enforced on the site so
I would like to ask whether there are
any intentions for that
uh I accept the point that there is more
control through having this planning
permission with conditions versus the
permitted development or pop-up use is
there any difference I mean we've got
the 56 days I think it was down as it
used to be 28 I seem to recall
um so presumably that's changed with the
pop-up situation
um but I'd like some um sort of
answers from the officer on that point
please
thank you councilor Haynes
um can I come to offices now or
and so I can pick up the point about the
condition
um in relation to noise
um I've just changed screen trying to
measure the size of the roof and the
condition three in the
um recommendation details the site noise
management plan and that shall be
provided and specifies that it shall
include noise management measures so
as as usual this isn't the full word and
the final wording of that condition so
the requirement to
have
circulate and stick to a noise
management plan would be embedded in
condition three as drafted here and
we don't have a requirement for water
butts at the moment and uh
I would expect it to be covered in our
we have an informative that goes on to
um almost all proposals now about you
know think about think about what you
can do where it's outside the scope of
planning rules to minimize your energy
and water usage and so it can definitely
be built in there I'm not sure that it
would be reasonable for us to build it
in to a condition and but obviously if
members want want to to consider and
propose that then that would be fine I
do think that
um we should have an additional
condition
um
that does confirm that the drainage
would be installed before the site was
operational and I can't see that one on
the list at the moment which is an
oversight on my behalf and putting this
together for you so that could form part
of that drainage condition so
um
anyway have you got the areas roughly
yeah I can just pick up on on some of
those points so with regards to the
environmental health officers comments
about the noise vehicle movements the
applicant updated the management plan
for the site to correspond with the
environmental officer's recommendation
so following that Amendment
um it's considered the management plan
for the site is acceptable to from the
environmental health point of view
um we've got to water butts I can't see
any water butts intake indicates on the
site plan however there is a garden and
allotment area in between the reception
area and the communal band so again I'm
sure you know the applicant would be
happy to put water bats into you know
collect the water to to water the
allotment there
um
with regards to the
size of the toilet block I've measured
that to be 133 square meters
um
yeah I think
I think it was
okay thank you and the camping the um
Barn picnic area looks similar in size
doesn't it so they're both roughly
whatever 10 by 10 ish and a bit
um in terms of the size of the roof area
that we're looking for the attenuation
from
10 by 10 meters yeah yeah
okay thank you
um
councilor con it
thank you chairman so for my clarity
then if the runoff is greater than one
liter per second what happens
why don't we condition the water butts
given the encouragement from surface
water and while the officer tells me the
applicant has updated the uh noise
management plan I didn't hear
specifically that no vehicle movements
will be allowed between 11 pm and 5 am
as the environmental health officer
appears to be encouraging can I have
some distinct clarity thank you
Rick
okay yeah I'm well familiar with this
site
um I mean I do think it's over
development it's currently a green field
I accept that it shows 56 weeks of the
year for campers but the rest of the
time it's a green field
um it is over development I have great
concerns about the noise pollution that
the development development will cause
particularly for local residents and
local residents have lived in their
homes probably for 50 60 years and I do
feel it's unreasonable to have a
campsite with 25 tents across the road
I've also got concerns about pedestrian
safety I I attend a regular weekly
evening meeting at dawlish Warren and
drive back past there the street
lighting is very very poor there's no
Street lighting outside the proposed
entrance either and it's not uncommon to
see people wandering back to the or say
wandering perhaps that's an unfortunate
word but on pedestrians walking back to
the site and occasionally they step into
the road so I do have concerns about
that and one other question if I may
please about the drainage I understand
it's being used at the moment so
presumably there are toilet facilities
there are they linked into the main
drain or do they give chemical toilets
or do they leak into a soak away
thank you
thank you for that and a couple more
points there I'm afraid which I'm going
to direct to officers too
see if they can answer
I understand as well counselor Wrigley
would like to to make another couple of
comments I'm happy to allow him to do so
so if you could while the officers are
having a look if you could
foreign
thank you it's clarification really on
the drainage because whilst the email
from the applicant that forwards on a
responsible telephone conversation with
Southwest water talks about the runoff
from the toilet block there is no
discussion whatsoever about the runoff
from the hard parking surface which is a
hard tarmac surface or indeed from the
other buildings on the site or the roofs
of the tents themselves
there is also as far as I can see no
drainage plan there
and I would like to know whether the
drainage officer has actually seen more
than he indicates in his response which
refers to this simple email of the 24th
of June that doesn't give any details so
there is no plan for the water and my
understanding is that it has been put
into the mains sewers as it stands
thank you
I'm sorry officers no that's that's fine
that's fine it is um inevitably
complicated when we've got a site that's
been in use albeit for a slightly
different use
um to date to make sure that we have the
right information in relation to what's
going to happen moving forwards rather
than what's happened to date
so um for clarity I think the
recommendation that we are putting to
you at the moment is the permission be
granted subject to our spotting
bottoming out matters relating to the
unilateral um undertaking for Habitat
mitigation in relation to the recreation
pressure at dawlish Warren so so we we
have agreement on the amount of money we
just need to make sure that we've got
the right words in the legal agreement
there so so
um we wouldn't be granting permission
today there's a subject to in there
um and I'm also proposing that we add in
an additional condition to those listed
in the recommendation that's before you
at the moment and to include a condition
that specifies that
um
the
drainage the surface water drainage from
the site
should be installed prior to the use of
the site being implemented
and that that should comply with the one
liter per second rate as identified in
the correspondence with Southwest water
so that is then attenuated rate one of
the ways that the attenuated rate could
be achieved is through the use of water
bugs and so I think it would be sensible
to include water butts as part of that
as well I'm happy for that to happen and
if it is not above ground what about
storage that would be included then it
would be below ground attenuation that
would be required as it would be on any
site and so the
um vast majority of the site would be
staying green and therefore permeable
and then for we shouldn't wouldn't
expect
um flows from the site to be above the
the existing Greenfield runoff rate I
appreciate that having a tent up might
might Focus some of that water in in
specific locations around the site but
overall the vast majority of the site we
wouldn't expect drainage to run off to
to exceed the current Greenfield runoff
rate so we're looking at
um uh the the surfaces of the roofs I
don't know whether the hard standing is
or isn't permeable
um I I haven't got that here but we're
looking particularly at the runoff from
the buildings which we know are the
impermeable areas being limited to one
liter per second
um at attenuated rates
um
going into the the combined uh Sue out
for pipe and so I'm happy for that to be
added as a condition
um Gary was there anything about the
management plan or anything I've missed
I'm still such I'm sure I've seen it
before I'm just trying to confirm it
okay so um in relation to the management
plan
um we I was intending to apply a
compliance condition
um because uh we had received what I
thought was a a good enough management
plan but if we can't find that and if
that hasn't been on on our website then
I I would
um adjust that condition so condition
three and that we would require the
submission of a management plan to make
sure that the quiet hours were being
achieved and I think 11 till 7 would be
what I would be expecting to see in that
so I would expect the quiet times to be
um at least 11 till 7 on site so rather
than it being a compliance condition we
would require the submission of an
up-to-date management plan that talked
about
um uh you know all of the things that
you'd expect about the way that people
behave and the way that noise at the
site was managed
thank you
we have had answers from from officers
are there any other points or questions
that members have at this point
counselor John pedrick
okay thank you very much indeed sorry I
might have missed it I asked a question
earlier about the drainage from the
toilet block
is this field already linked into the
Southwest water sewer system or not
councilor Wrigley seemed to indicate
that it might be but is it does it have
main strainers at the moment thank you
thank you
[Music]
um I haven't been out there since last
summer but I understand it was temporary
blocks so I would have thought it's not
linked up to but yeah I need to clarify
that
so if that needs clarifying are we able
to take a decision on this at this point
from my perspective it's irrelevant to
the plan and consideration and for them
to be able to operate the campsite they
would need to be able to dispose of
their foul and there are a number of
Residential Properties in the area a
number of businesses in the area I would
expect that they would be able to
requisition the connection to to the
foul sewage in this area
thank you
um okay any other comments or questions
from Members we haven't had a proposal
or we of of any sort
um on this but we have had um lots of
questions and
um and now we've had our answers so any
other thoughts from members of the
committee please
so we're sitting here with a proposal as
set out but with all of the condition
the additional
conditions mentioned by officers our
members content for us to move forward
with that
menstruation
thank councilor Haynes did you want to
get that on the microphone sorry
thank you yeah I'd like to move the
recommendation of set out chairman thank
you with the additional I'm assuming
that's with the sorry with the
additional conditions that uh head of
planning said okay thank you councilor
Haines
um Council McGregor you wanted to speak
on this just a second The Proposal as
stated by councilor Haynes okay thank
you
um so if there's no other comments or
statements to make we will go to the
vote please
can I see an indication of those members
who want to vote for this proposal
please
and any against
and any abstentions
so I'm afraid the proposal has failed
um
so excuse me chair um
we do
councilor con it chairman so the motion
has set out failed presumably those who
voted against now need to put forward a
motion to refuse with the reasons for
their refusal and if they don't wish to
do that I think we should re-run the
original vote again to give members a
chance to reflect okay thank you for
that
um so I'm now waiting for a a proposal
from the members who wanted to refuse
this item to give their reasons please
Council Connor in the absence of that
may I suggest that the original proposal
has put by councilor Haynes and seconded
by Council McGregor is we put to the
committee
have no other option to do that
um I'd like to okay
yeah is anyone happy to second that
proposal
councilor McGregor
so we will go back to the original
proposal for from councilor Haynes
um
with
no well nothing to add to what I said
earlier that's fine thank you and
seconded by councilor McGregor to go
forward with this item as set out with
the conditions as before so can I call
for a vote please
those four
okay and those against
and those abstaining
okay
so
the vote four has it as I understand it
it really is I thought once we've
refused it yes
it was it was refused as set up but it
was there was no other substantive
motion for us to take forward
yes chair that needs to be a proposer
and and a supporter a second for there
to be
for it to be refused if the original
vote fails and it just goes back to a
someone needs to suggest something so
for lawful Clarity chairman As I
understood it the proposal to approve
was lost there was no counter proposal
to refuse and in that absence it was
then re-put to the committee perhaps the
council's lawyer could advise us so we
are certain that we've taken a lawful
decision today thank you are you able to
put just on that button
thank you that that's correct
okay short and sweet okay
so that is carried and set out with the
um the conditions as per
um the officers on that so we move on to
the next item on the agenda
and we we now have the
um enforcement report
thank you
very nice chair my um my battery was
dying so we're just going to get the
other laptop hooked on okay
let's go and sit down
yeah
all right okay
foreign
okay
so we have the higher collie Brook Farm
enforcement
item
I do have a warm Bend member who wants
to speak but if you could take us
through it first please
thank you chairman this is one where um
we received a complaint about a section
of Hedgerow being taken out at uh higher
collie Brook Farm in idfit
um on the side shows you can see
um
it sort of sets out where it is the um
the main house that's recently built is
down to one end of the side there's a
public footpath that goes up the side of
it
um there was an existing access into the
site here and a smaller one has been
created at the top here
just go through the views of sex sorry
here's the
view taken from next to the house it
goes up the um footpath the side of the
property
um this is the open the existing opening
it's been there for a considerable time
um another view of the same opening
and then
further up towards the top of the site
and the footpath goes through the
kissing gate at the end there but the
access has been created is there on the
left hand side
and further view of the opening which is
about three meters in width
and there's the gate that sort of input
sort of set back in to the site
and that's just another view sort of
looking at the footpath going up through
from the sort of beginning of the
footpath up to the top in this instance
we the owner was advised that they
needed um consent or should have contact
us before taking the hedgeville out
um to comply with the Hedgerow
regulations
um they didn't do that
um despite being chased on it
um as such we had to make a decision on
whether it was expedient to take
enforcement action against it and
following consultations with the um tree
officer and our biodiversity officers
although they agreed that there was
probably a breach it wasn't something
that was expedient to take enforcement
action against
the access back to that
um more recently I've been in contact
with the owner to find out into trying
to resolve the matter
um they've come back so I said well they
need it to help maintain the track it's
privately owned and they take their
vehicle up to the top there and they you
reverse into that opening there and to
save Damage Reverse all the way back
down again and so they wish to retain it
and um don't see that it's very big and
I've had sort of positive comments about
the The Works they've been carried out
on the track to try and maintain it
so okay thank you so the the options
before us I believe are that we
um asked for
um
no further action to be taken that's the
recommendation yes thank you okay I have
a ward member
um who wishes to speak on this item
councilor Beryl Austin
thank you chairman three just three
minutes I know you have as much time as
you like actually now beg your pardon
thank you I'm representing councilor
Pitt who is present on holiday in
Tenerife and I'm not a member of the
planning committee so therefore I can't
make her a proposal so I'll just report
the delegated report clearly states that
a breach has occurred
that the owner should have contacted the
council and sought permission for any
Works to the established Health uh
Hedgerow
the route has been widened of the foot
path by the farmers and the Hedge
substantial part of a protected Devon
hedge has been removed
saplings have been cut down in the
pathway
trees have been cut down
the narrow diverse nature of the public
footpath has been completely altered
before two people could comfortably walk
down the path
enjoying at Canada trees and Banks
covered with wild flowers
Banks and footpath surfaces have been
scraped away and the whole area altered
now neither the new access or the
original access have been closed
the whole operation was completed in a
weekend without any consultation or
permission or without any thought for
the environment
or the um the views of the parish
the community would expect the area to
be reinstated in view of the official
view that the removal of the Hedge Rose
was against regulations
to create a new access without
permission
so it should be reinstated that is the
regulation
there were already three entrances
giving access to the farm
too adequate entrances are there halfway
down the footpath
there was no need to remove the existing
protected Hedge trees both side of the
path
were then also removed
the parish consider that an historic
public footpath which has been there for
80 years has been changed and the Hedge
removed and the whole thing should be
restored to its original state I cannot
make the proposal chairman but I would
welcome if a council could do that on my
behalf
thank you Luke thank you if you want to
retake your seat or okay
um so any members thoughts or questions
on on this item please
I don't know who quite was first
thank you thank you that's liquor as
well yes thank you chairman
um it really annoys me when we are
looking for retrospective permission
um
I believe that whoever did this
um work to the
um pathway knew they needed position
permission
you can't plead ignorance it's it's what
everybody does
and we get this far too often and then
the officers come back and say it's not
worth pursuing
and I for one think it is worth pursuing
thank you
councilor Clarence you wanted to to
speak on that
oh there it is sorry I was waiting for
him yeah thank you very much
has he actually done anything illegal
because I've had this in my own patch
where people have just pulled those
through a hedge or offer a small sea
Road and nothing's been done about it at
all and that's all for a minor road
because it's a minor Road you you can
there's no reason why you shouldn't take
down a demon bank I I I refer to sort of
the the pickethead hill region of
children where that's happened so how's
this chap done anything illegal
um so just to for Clarity on that point
I think there's a that we need to be
careful we don't conflate a couple of
issues here and there is a permitted
development right to create a new access
um off an unclassified Road
um uh this so that's that's a planning
permission question
um in this instance what we're dealing
with is a breach of potential a breach
of the Hedgerow regulations
so if you if you have what is classified
as an important hedge and then you need
to apply for permission to the local
Authority for removal of elements of
that hedge and if your hedge isn't
important then
um uh there are different regulations
and different rules that apply so we
have decided that
the Hedgerow regulations did apply in
this instance but that the Hedge was not
important the importance is conferred by
species mix length and a number of other
um Criterion so
um in considering whether or not we felt
that we should serve a hedge row
replacement notice
and we considered that the hetero wasn't
important that doesn't mean that we
don't think that the Hedgerow is
important that's important you know in
inverted commas in line with the the
rules are set out in the legislation and
so having taken into account the fact
that we did not consider the Hedgerow to
be important
um that this was um something that would
not need planning permission that it was
a three meter wide Gap
and that if they had applied to us in
the first place we probably would have
given approval for The Works to be
undertaken we did not consider that it
was necessary for a Hedgerow replacement
or replanting notice to be issued so
that was the decision that that we took
as officers we then um sent out our
usual closed cases report in relation to
this matter and councilor Pat disagreed
so this has come before you guys to see
whether you agree with our view that it
is not in the public interest for this
three meter wide gap of Hedgerow to be
replanted or whether you think that we
should be issuing a Hedgerow replacement
notice
thank you for that Clarity um councilor
McGregor you wanted to come in on this
thank you Jay
um just wanted to ask that the path
that's being maintained is that a public
right-of-way
um there's a public right-of-way but
it's privately owned by the person who's
carried out the works so there you have
to maintain it
um but it is it's got a problem right
away through it
okay so it would be normal for anybody
maintaining a public right-of-way to
remove undergrowth and intrusion plants
onto that public right away as part of
that maintenance I believe so yes the
issue for the Hedge funding is which we
come across quite often that's a
separate issue oh yeah thanks anyways
just to clarify that specific point that
was raised uh in the um objectors
um speech thank you
thank you councilor Dewhurst wants to
speak here
that thank you chair
um just coming back to the the statement
made by our planning manager
um the word just like a bit of
clarification around the word probably
um
because
what I think we want to know is would
the council have put a Hedgerow order in
or would they not clearly if they would
have put an order in to have the hedge
row reinstated then in my view we should
be voting to to to ensure that happens
if if they wouldn't then then
clearly we shouldn't be voting for that
and I'd really like clarification and
probably in my view doesn't help so
thank you sorry if I take you to 3.5 of
the report
um the words that I used in writing were
that if it's considered that if the
council had been notified of the
proposed work it is highly likely
approval would have been given so the
important bit is if we were told in
advance as with any planning application
and there is that public consultation
element and that's the bit that's
missing obviously with with the
retrospective nature of this proposal
and there is nothing that has come out
through the enforcement process that
makes me think that we wouldn't have
done but obviously it's really difficult
to be determinative when you don't have
that application in front of you and you
haven't gone through the the the the the
full process that you would in those
circumstances so you know I I uh
maintain my slight caveat but I don't
think that that we as an officer group
would have had any concern with this
proposal
okay thank you councilor con it you
wanted to come in and then Council
McGregor thank you
which I I wanted to ask
I think what I'm hearing is that the
people who did the work should have
asked they didn't ask but had they asked
we probably would have approved it
so how do we stop people doing things in
the first place that we should have
asked for that's the issue here isn't it
because right across Cambridge people
will feel that you can just do it and
then the council will take a balance of
probability issue with it and it strikes
me here that I can quite accept that the
office of view is that the Hedge might
well have been of low value that we
wouldn't have objected to the work but
they didn't ask and if the word gets out
as it probably is that you just do
things and then you come back and plead
uh you know for clemency what's to stop
people just doing things left right and
center the issue for me is not whether
the head should be put back or not I can
quite accept there's a professional view
it was low quality but how do we stop
people just ripping out Hedges
willy-nilly and saying well what are you
going to do about it
Point taking councilor McGregor you
wanted to come back in
thank you Jay I was just that actually
my my point was answered by the business
planning manager but thank you very much
thank you I have to concur 100 precisely
with Alan comet on this this is exactly
what has happened in my patch and and my
members are gonna of my constituents I
think are going to be pretty mad when
they hear this so I think we've got to
sort of tighten up our policies on this
so so that people do have to ask and if
they're going to plow into Devin Banks
and just rip them out willy-nilly as is
clearly my area I'm not happy with this
at all yeah what's going on here as Alan
connett alluded to thank you
I appreciate your point on that but
we're not dealing with the Devon Bank on
on this item and I I appreciate the
emotion with you you're saying with that
we're talking about a a Hedgerow yeah
also just for clarity um as with most
planning legislation there are
allowances for um retrospective
applications made in the legislation
whilst I understand and appreciate the
concerns you know if those allowances
are built into the legislation it's
difficult for us to take an alternative
stance and as we consider our work on a
case-by-case basis
um we don't get very many Hedgerow
applications and but I wouldn't want to
say that we would treat them all you
know this isn't that just because we
think this one was okay doesn't mean
that we wouldn't think that the next one
wasn't
at many hedger applications because
unfortunately the majority of people are
just ripping into them and nobody's
doing anything about it that's why we
need to close it we need to have a look
at this
thank you Council Clarence councilor
Bradford you'd like to come in on this
and then cancel the Dewhurst
thank you chair
um I think that these people ought to be
made to put another Hedgerow up
um whether the Hedgerow was deemed
important or Not by us
um it was important to the wildlife and
the birds that were in it and we've lost
so many much wildlife and birds through
the last few decades so I think that
we'd be setting a president if we didn't
um
so they should put a new one up thank
you
thank you and councilor Dewhurst
so thank you chair just for the benefit
of the record I 100 agree with
everything that has been said by my
colleagues here councilor conic
councilor Clarence everybody I I I think
it's a disgrace and that this is
happening but the reality is that we are
looking at
um at a technical thing and the
technical thing is is that there is a
recommendation here if we go against
that recommendation there could be an
appeal against that recommendation uh
against our decision and and ending up
with huge expense for everybody the
council and on all of us and of course
the council taxpayers
um could I maybe uh make a
recommendation that we accept the
recommendation in 4 0.1 but also
recommend that Cambridge Council
instigates a uh
a media campaign around the protection
of hedgerows because I can't think that
there can be a single one of us sitting
here today who represents any kind of
rural part of this uh lovely District
who hasn't had this issue take place and
and
um I I think it's an absolute disgrace
that we are losing our hedgerows all the
time what I don't want to do is end up
with a recommendation here that we can't
defend and and just everybody's put to
more expense more problems it shouldn't
be happening in the first place
thank you thank you councilor Dewhurst
so
um you have proposed that we accept our
set out with that with that Proviso
um
I have councilor McGregor first and then
I'll bring you your bring you in
thank you Joe just a second councilor
junhurst's proposal thank you on that
councilor Kurzweil
I just wanted to make the point that
every month when we have our list of
enforcements coming through and I do
read them thoroughly and yes we do have
the replies no breach breach rectified
um breach worth not worth pursuing
um and there are a lot of these not
worth pursuing and I would actually like
a little caveat on the bottom of that
and saying why it's not worth pursuing
because it may not be a Hedgerow it
could be somebody building a wall it
could be somebody doing an extension it
could be all sorts of things and some of
these things are important and sometimes
quite often more often than not probably
um people are just trying to get away
with it and uh and they're not playing
by the rules and we have rules to be
adhered to thank you
thank you for that and point taken and I
think
um councilor Parker
can I just inform the committee that
there is currently a task and finish
group for enforcement taking place I'm a
member of that we have one more meeting
to go and I'd be gladly bringing this
point to that group so that we can
discuss it further and I know Rose will
probably be at that meeting as well so I
totally agree with everything that's
been said and I think we should discuss
that at that task at Finish group and
perhaps bring a recommendation forward
on that basis
thank you for that counselor Parker I
think that's a really good idea and I
hope members who are uncomfortable with
this and who've spoken to that point are
comfortable with the The Proposal that
we've now has been brought forward and
has been seconded as well so
um on that basis I'm going to ask
members to come to the vote on that
please
sorry
sorry chair I don't have either the
resources or the capacity personally to
undertake any kind of media campaign in
relation to hedgerows so I'm concerned
um about members taking a vote that
suggests that we do that when I don't
that's not within my remit so we were
just chatting for for one moment about
um what that would do in terms of your
recommendation and or your proposal so
obviously I'm quite happy that the
proposal has been made that you know
that you agree with our recommendation
but we think the second part of that
maybe is is for for members to take up
personally or to further the executive
member with that responsibility to
consider how they would take that
forward and so we were just exercising a
note of caution before you voted chair
thank you thank you for that quick step
in councilor con it you wanted to come
in then councilor Clarence then Council
McGregor
thank you chairman I'm surprised to hear
uh well the head of planning is saying I
would have thought quite simply that the
recommendation would have enabled
officers to have taken that issue up the
will of the committee with the council's
communications chief that being fed into
a council's communication program uh
without any time being taken by the head
of uh planning and pursuing that I don't
think anyone in the committee was
suggesting that planning officers
directly uh went out and did that but
actually used the internal functions and
certainly individual members won't have
the same weight as the decision of the
committee chairman or I thought that
would have been a simple and
straightforward way forward thank you
thank you for that we've also had
councilor Parker mentioned the task and
finish group that I think was a a good
solution from that point of view but I
have other members who wanted to speak
to
um councilor
McGregor and then councilor Clarence
please
well I just wanted to concur with what
Alan Connor has said actually he's the
leader of this Council after all thank
you
uh councilor McGregor and then councilor
Haynes
um councilor con its uh superbly
articulated point about the
communications process I think uh stands
quite well but it for the purposes of
the
um the proposal perhaps councilor
Dewhurst might want to just reduce it
slightly take that element out and I'm
happy to Second it again thank you
thank you if I can ask you to consider
that counselor Dewhurst while I now go
to councilor Haynes please
thank you chairman we're here to
consider a planning application not what
the council is going to be doing in
terms of publicity uh I think the
recommendation as it is is the one we
should be voting on but the other matter
should be referred to the enforcement
working group as has been said it's not
a matter really for the planning
committee as I understand it
thank you for that cancer Dewhurst
um can we can we take it that although
you mentioned the media
um article and we've also had com
conversation and and points made by uh
councilor Parker about the task and
finish group that we can take it back to
the actual resolution that
um we propose to accept our set out
thank you chair so so I've listened and
I believe there is an absolute cry from
members here about this issue so I don't
particularly want to change my uh
Amendment what I would do though to
change it is to add a piece about that
it goes to the task and finish group
about planning enforcement
um but but I take as Deputy leader of
the council I take counselor con its
comments I don't wish our planning
officers to be spending any time on this
this is uh part of our internal
functions uh of having a media
operation within the council I want that
message out there that people should
know that they must not be making holes
in Hedges unless they've got permission
thank you thank you for that Clarity
okay Council
U.S proposal that we amend our
additional comment or whatever it is
with some reference to the task and
finish group so it's perfectly clear
we're not assuming that planning will do
anything about it thank you counseling
at all okay so we now have an amended
proposal and a second so but it is to
um
just to clarify the point you're
comfortable thank you but um we take a
vote on the fact that no further action
is taken on this
um however with the Proviso of
um more publicity about this and the
task and finish group okay
so those four The Proposal please
those against
and I don't think there'll be any
abstentions but I'll ask for abstentions
because I think that's all of us
included thank you
so that is carried
and next
let's see the next item if I don't
manage to break the microphone we need
to note the
um
two items the major variation
application
um I don't know if officers need to
mention this we don't need to vote on it
it's just to note
and we also have appeal decisions to
know members are comfortable to note
those items
um well while I never have a note I draw
members attention to the most peculiar
decision of the inspector in relation to
Exley in the Gateway at Star Cross a
more bizarre and perverse decision I
couldn't imagine absolutely destroying a
lovely Greystone wall off the main a379
uh I just wonder you know sometimes we
go to planning inspectors and
um you know they have to balance but you
know that Gateway is being wrecked
um and and I just can't fathom what it
is the planning inspector thought he was
thinking of thank you
I don't think there's anything else we
can take further with that but but your
comments are noted from that point of
view members thank you for your patience
today I don't think we've been here too
long but um thank you for your attention
um and I declare the meeting closed if
you could wait until the cameras and
microphones Etc are Switched Off
um
thank you